how would you spend your ideal Saturday
night on a date with an intergalactic
bay hmm sounds interesting
[Music]
hey guys we're here with BuzzFeed and
we're going to take a which Star Wars
character are you quiz shall we yes how
would you spend your ideal Saturday
night there's options here a home with
pets at a bar drinking with my friends
on a date with an intergalactic bay
watching revenge on my enemies what is a
babe
that means babe and sort of Nathaniel
speak I think it stands for something
business I thought it was just buried
without the baby Oh meaning it's not
it's not the best anyone ever like I
said I know immediately what my answer
is at home with pets I would say binge
watching my favorite TV show and
everyone's like wow and that is why she
doesn't prep it she's a ship to cruise
the galaxy with lambda 1.is million
faulted the Star Destroyer a TIE fighter
x-wing boom what have you Starfighter or
I'll stay on land in way speeder speeder
not Speedos she's a ship to cruise the
galaxy with yep because cruise to me is
implying but rest and relaxation there
has to be room for a spa that's really
clever and by the way you know swatching
this guy fly his x-wing around like the
coffee fire lady is makes me very
nostalgic for the good old days if I go
looking at a bunch of kids rifling
through your toy box thank you for
letting us play with your toys yeah I'm
staying on lunch oh yeah there's nothing
for me in space there's a chessboard in
the Millennium Falcon and I can't play
chess so we'll go for that and you can't
play chess yeah I can learn you could
teach yourself chess
I'll teach mice that is the saddest just
me and a chessboard crazy 30 minutes
fall
they've got bad you know insects and
stuff and men in Falcon the Star
Destroyer everybody wants to fly kill
you the Thai fire everybody else wants
to kill you I'm having a Thai fighter
because I like that element of risk too
my favorites are done though you can
also go with those oh no off stay on
land in my speed which quality is most
important even a friend okay humor
compassion honesty adventurous
creativity ambition Oscar Isaacs
ambition I'm one of the blunt honesty do
you that's what you want yeah straight
down he'll be straight
[Laughter]
yeah I know I thought there's a dark
side that's a dark who would pick
honesty in showbiz I'll go in venture
confession what a kind man
I would say that's humor that is so
important to deal with harsh reality I'm
gonna go with humor
can I pick two adventurous and
compassion choose an original trilogy
character to be your partner in crime
we have Yoda yeah
we have obi-wan Kenobi Lando Calrissian
Darth Vader r2d2 and solo either that
partner in crime it's gotta be vader
Lando sir cool
Yoda 1 million percent
I'm so much too old Maps no good is
right just right no live forever ask
your partner in crime yoga
cuz he's tiny and he can get in places
you know if we were gonna like what are
your oven
I figured up a a priest every school
better
I'm gonna go Hans Billy Dee come on ya
know how can I not choose Sir Alec
Guinness yeah obi-wan Kenobi
here we choose Vader you know why I'll
be in the car if you can go and do but
do we need to do there not be in the car
to drive you out baby
I want han Solo so I can get off with
them choose a Star Wars quote to tattoo
on your body and the choices are you're
my only hope I find your lack of faith
disturbing
do or do not there as I Drive and also
depending where you've got I've got a
bad feeling about this
never tell me the odds again odd may the
force be with you always
I've got a bad feeling about this where
would you have that mean tattooed on
your body this is an odd one there's no
two ways about it I've got a bad feeling
about this
I was thinking the same yeah where would
you get it I um you know one truth it's
time for the tattoos to end so I'm
picking the shortest one I mean the
least verbiage choice between year my
only hope and never tell me the odds
never tell me the odds I'm going never
telling the guys as well I think all
three guys matching tattoo yeah I'm
gonna tube and I got my character this
just makes me feel bad
I got Finn I got ray
all right naga i got general layout how
did that happen just me i got kind of
ready yeah oh what a surprise
I'm like kylo Ren and you're passionate
driven probably have a really cool mom
boom I do have a really cool mom
nice yeah very well than from Russia's
business TBH don't know who that is
while your emotions while your emotions
can sometimes be misdirected you're a
strong person that you're cool you're a
badass plain and simple cool calm and
collected you've never once let a bad
situation get in the way of your success
also you're one hell of a pilot you
certainly feeling great you've certainly
lived through some difficult experiences
in this life but you're incredibly
self-sufficient thanks to those trying
times because of your brave nature and
resilience you're someone others look to
for leadership under 30 caring person in
a time when those qualities are sorely
needed you fight for what you believe is
right them after the consequences you're
willing to sacrifice everything you have
for the well-being of those you care
about something not many humans or
droids consider about themselves well
that's lovely it's not yeah I mean it
it's nowhere near the truth no I fall
into the dogs I know a few times in life
I represent a standard human
understanding human package to yours
well I'm sure it's because I picked
humor because it said you got general
Leia you're a natural-born leader who
could win over anyone with your wit you
have a take-no-prisoners way about you
and absolutely nothing can stop you from
achieving your goals not to mention
you're a galactic icon icon not believe
it I would be Luke Skywalker
that's pretty and John you're gonna what
battery okay you're naturally a gifted
person you have a unbelievable intuition
and your moral compass guides you
through everything you do your feared by
some but believed by many including me
John I've got askew
I can't let you Michael of you here yeah
yeah I got it first thing I'll kill you
you published it saying that you've got
general Leia I did my god keep this man
away from big and her now he's a menace